Speaker 1: I saw a super interesting headline
this morning about the U.S. military. And we've
talked about the U.S. military so much on
this program. It relates to foreign policy,
it relates to budgetary priorities. It relates
to culture in many ways because there is this
military culture that exists in the United States.
Okay. So what's the headline? The headline from
the Army Times is that the Army has missed its
recruiting goal by about 15,000 soldiers. And as
you read through the article by Lolita Baldor
from the Associated Press, you see that that
15,000 soldier shortfall is about 25%
of its recruitment goal this year. Now,
at big companies, when you miss earnings
projections by 2%, it's a pretty big deal.
So understand that falling 25% short and
the military is a large organization,
falling 25% short of your recruitment goal
for a year is a really, really big deal. The
article also points out that all military services
struggled in what they're describing as a tight
jobs market to find young people both willing
and fit to enlist, adding while the Army was
the only service that didn't meet its target, all
others had to dig deep into their pool of delayed
entry applicants, which will put them behind as
they begin the next recruiting year on Saturday.
The article, to its credit, says the worsening
problem stirs debate about whether America's
fighting force should be restructured or reduced
in size if the services can't recruit enough,
and also puts added pressure on National Guard
and Reserves to help meet mission requirements.
So there's actually a bunch of interesting
layers to this conversation. First of all,
is just the question why aren't as many people
as at times past applying, or are the people
applying not meaning the relatively modest but
but still their requirements for joining the
military when it comes to physical fitness and
health conditions and this sort of thing? One
really interesting aspect to this is that wages
are up in many sectors, including sectors that
could be alternatives to joining the military.
And if you look at wage and salary growth in
the United States, this is a chart looking at the
last 25 years. You see that basically dating back
to sort of early in 2020, the pandemic, quite
frankly, there has been significant wage growth
in the United States. Now there are those who will
say this is a good thing because people are making
more. Some on the right who often criticize
lack of wage growth when there's a Democratic
president now say the wage growth is bad because
it's part of inflation, which is making it hard to
hire people. The rate is going to say it's bad
no matter what if a Democrat is in office. But
let's be quite frank and direct about this. If you
can make a better wage not joining the military,
there are lots of people who will choose to do the
job outside of the military or said a different
way. When wages aren't as oppressively low outside
of the military, it's going to be bad for military
recruiting. Now, there's also sort of political
reasons why folks might not be jumping to sign up
for the military at this point in time. Look at
someone like Republican Congressman Matt Gaetz,
who over the last week has been in a bunch of
viral video clips saying, why don't we get rid
of the VA altogether, the Veterans Affairs
Department. And of course, you might believe
that he really wants to improve care for veterans
by getting rid of the VA and doing it a different
way. But for the most part, veterans like the VA
and it's probably not helping recruiting that you
have even Republicans who are supposedly always
for the military and veterans openly hostile to
some of the aspects of the military world, which
includes the VA and saying we should we should get
rid of that. We have the stories of female service
members regularly assaulted and worried that if
they report the assault within the military, they
will be sent for a psych eval, may be deemed unfit
for service, and they are the ones who who will
suffer rather than the person they accuse of
assaulting them. But that's just the kind of nitty
gritty of why might we be seeing this problem. And
of course, you can also make the claim, although
I don't have data on it, that maybe. People who
are targeted by the military to join are seeing it
as a valiant mission compared to at times past. We
know recruiting after 911 went sky high because so
many people thought, if I join the military now,
I'm going to be able to do something to stop or
hurt the people that did. 911 Then they were sent
to Iraq, which had nothing to do with 911, and
the rest is history. But that's not the story
for today. But there's a whole other aspect to
this, which is it should make us ask the question,
why does the military need to be so big? And we
can talk about big in terms of what it costs,
but also huge militaries can cause foreign policy
blunders. And we've seen this in the past. If you
look at stories from the Korean War, Vietnam to
some degree, when you have a really big military,
it can make one believe that it is even more
powerful and invulnerable. And you make military
decisions that go above and beyond even the
power that you have. And it can lead to very bad
military decision. Decisions create quagmires of
endless, sort of like a constant rotation of loss
of life. It's kind of what's happening to the
Russian military in Ukraine right now. They do
have the stronger military, but they overstated in
their own minds even the strength. And so there's
lots of geopolitical reasons why having a big
military isn't necessarily the best thing. And of
course, if you're someone like me, a progressive
social Democrat, I want I'm not for abolishing the
military, but I recognize there are threats to the
United States. The U.S. should have a military,
but it shouldn't be nearly as large and far
reaching as the one we have is. And so much of
the money that is spent on defense could be better
spent elsewhere. I won't give you the full rant of
all the areas in which it could be spent, but I've
many clips and stories about that. So needless to
say, the military struggling to recruit what comes
next. And to be clear, this has nothing to do with
Joe Biden. There are I saw anecdotally on Twitter
people saying this is because Biden has disgraced
the country so no one wants to serve. There's no
evidence of that whatsoever. I also saw this is
because of Joe Biden's student loan debt relief,
because one of the reasons people were joining
the military was because they needed money
to pay off their student loans. First of all,
that debt relief was only just announced and that
couldn't possibly be the reason why in the last
year there was a shortfall in recruiting.
And number two, you're sort of saying like,
we need to keep people really desperate
financially so that they'll join the military.
That's not really that doesn't speak wonders
about the American military, if that's what
it takes. Let me know your thoughts. I don't know
that this problem is going to abate any time soon